what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and did you know that
there is a secret message hidden in the
one piece logo if you take away the o at
the beginning and the luffy shaped eye
and if you pretend that the end is
actually an x and you turn the p upside
down you get the word zebek
okay i'm messing with you but the
legendary pirate rox d zebic is indeed
one of the biggest and most insane
mysteries in one piece in many ways rox
actually created the modern one-piece
world as we know it his legacy literally
shaped the story and yet we know almost
nothing about him but what if i told you
that zebek will play a major role in the
final saga of the one piece story and
that he may even be directly related to
luffy the truth about zebic is about to
change everything so let's get into it
you guys know how this works leave a
quick like and comment if you enjoy our
videos it only takes you a second but it
helps us out with that youtube algorithm
and if you're new to anime uproar or
maybe you watch our videos regularly but
you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications finally this video
will of course contain one piece manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned rox d zebek was an
infamous pirate who terrorized the world
of one piece some four decades ago long
before the current age of piracy began
with the death of goldie roger in fact
the rise of rocks predated the rise of
roger and once roger did come into his
own as a powerful pirate rox was
considered to be his greatest rival from
the d initial in his name we know that
rox was a member of the d-clan and we
know that his goal was to become the
king of the world presumably he wanted
to sit on the empty throne and rule over
the entire world with an iron fist
this sets him apart from other d-clan
pirates like luffy and roger who wanted
to become the pirate king in order to be
the freest men on the seas their goal
was freedom and adventure whereas rox's
goal appears to have been wealth and
power rox also differs from pirates like
luffy and roger when it comes to tactics
he was willing to do whatever it takes
to achieve his goals and he had no
problem with killing anyone who dared to
stand in his way his crew was not one
that prized friendship and loyalty
instead it revolved around strength and
rivalry it appears that rox's crewmates
didn't even really like him as a person
but they still fought alongside him
because he was such a fierce and
powerful pirate they likely believed
that rox was the only one who could make
their ambitious dreams come true and so
they followed him in spite of his
ruthless and untrustworthy nature and
speaking of rox's crew it was probably
the single most impressive crew that
ever existed in the history of one piece
zebeck's crew consisted of a young
whitebeard kaido big mom shiki and
captain jack among others the first
three went on to become yonko and the
other two became legends in their own
right since we know that these famous
crew members didn't necessarily like
zebic and some like big mom even had
blatantly negative opinions about him
there had to be something that kept his
crew together and in my opinion the one
thing that could keep all of these
massive personalities with huge egos on
the same page is none other than zebec's
ambition and of course strength since he
was one of the strongest pirates in
existence and kaido put him right up
there with whitebeard roger odin and
shanks
zebek was clearly a very ambitious man
who had an important mission for a long
time he had been interested in the
secret history of the world he was
determined to get his hands on forbidden
knowledge and he openly declared war on
the world government vowing to overthrow
the current system and become the king
of the world he showed a willingness to
kill even the celestial dragons
themselves on top of their slaves and
everyone else who dared to challenge him
more than 40 years ago he gathered his
crew on the island of hachinosu and set
out to accomplish his ultimate goal
although the specifics of that goal are
still unknown other than the fact that
he declared war on the world government
and that he wanted to be the king of the
world we know very little about rox's
true intentions his combat strategy and
his ultimate motivations why was he
doing what he was doing was it just for
wealth and power or was there more to
the story the only major clue that we
have about rox's ultimate goal is the
infamous god valley incident which
occurred 38 years ago the entire
incident was deliberately hushed up and
concealed from the world by the world
government and today only the older
generations of marines are even aware
that the incident occurred we know that
zepek and his overpowered crew attacked
a mysterious island called god valley
and according to sengoku multiple
celestial dragons were present on god
valley at the time of the attack sengoku
didn't specify how many celestial
dragons were present or which ones were
actually there we just know that some of
them were on the island along with their
slaves it is possible that these were
high-ranking world nobles such as the
gorosei because in order to defeat zebek
and protect these celestial dragons the
world government resorted to something
unheard of they actually teamed up with
the future pirate king goldie roger in
order to take zebic down garp and roger
worked together to defeat zebek and it
was during this battle that garp earned
his title as hero of the marines after
what must have been one of the greatest
battles in the history of one piece
zebek was defeated and the rock's
pirates were dissolved unfortunately we
still know very little about the battle
itself and how exactly garp and roger
managed to win but that is precisely
what makes this legendary incident so
fascinating practically every one piece
fan is hoping for an extended god valley
flashback that will finally reveal how
it all went down and that will allow us
to learn more about the mysterious rocks
d zebic as i said before the truth about
the entire incident was then heavily
censored by the world government and the
island of god valley itself vanished
from the face of the earth we don't know
how or why it vanished but now it is
gone and it cannot be found on any map
also this presumably isn't an instance
of the world government calling in a
buster call to blow everything up on the
island in sengoku's own words the island
disappeared entirely if it had been
destroyed by a buster call he could have
just said that but even though the world
government attempted to erase zebec and
god valley from history they could not
erase zebec's legacy and in many ways
zebek completely changed the world of
one piece and he shaped it into what it
is today roger garp whitebeard big mom
and kaido wouldn't have become the
people we know today if it wasn't for
zebic meaning that we may not have even
had a new golden age of piracy and luffy
may never have become a pirate if it
weren't for zebic if you're interested
in how zebek impacted the world of one
piece including the entire warlord
system the rise of blackbeard and even
luffy's own journey check out our video
explaining all 10 members of the d-clan
and their powers link in the description
naturally because of all the mystery
that surrounds both zebec and god valley
there is no shortage of theories about
all of this within the one piece
community and some of these theories are
truly compelling and if they turned out
to be true they would explain a lot
about the world of one piece and about
the family history of several important
characters such as luffy and shanks the
first theory i want to discuss is the
theory that rox d zepek is actually
luffy's other grandfather there are two
versions of this theory one states that
luffy's mother is actually the daughter
of zebek and she may have first come
into contact with garp and his son
dragon during the god valley incident we
know that garp always wanted both his
son and his grandson to follow in his
footsteps and to become marines so it is
possible that a young dragon was
actually there with garp at the time of
the god valley incident dragon would
have been like 17 years old back then so
he may have been a new recruit or a
marine in training under the direct
supervision of his father garp in their
capacity as marines garp and dragon
would have been tasked with rescuing the
celestial dragons before zebek got to
them dragon may have taken part in this
rescue operation which would explain why
garp fought so hard to protect the
celestial dragons even though he hates
them and it would also explain why garp
was willing to work with roger even
though he hates pirates if his own son
was present on the island then his son's
safety would also depend on garp
defeating zebek so garp did what he had
to do not just to protect the world
nobles whom he hates but also to protect
his own son
and what if zebek had a daughter and
after his ultimate defeat at god valley
that daughter was taken into custody by
the marines
while in custody this daughter could
have met garp and dragon and perhaps
eventually her and dragon fell in love
since the world government was so
determined to erase zebek and the god
valley incident from history it's
possible that they were planning to
execute everyone associated with zebec
in any way including his daughter even
if she did nothing wrong
and that could be the moment that dragon
turned against the world government and
embarked on a personal mission to
destroy it instead of executing zebek's
daughter he betrayed the marines and ran
away with her and so dragon became an
outlaw and fugitive from that day
forward and while we don't know what
happened to luffy's mom after that her
absence from the story could be directly
connected to the fact that she is
zebec's daughter and that means that the
world government wants to eliminate her
at all costs so it would make sense for
her to keep a distance from luffy
because she doesn't want luffy to get
involved the second version of this
theory also suggests that zebec is
luffy's other grandfather but not
because zebek is the father of luffy's
mom but rather because zebek is actually
the real father of luffy's dad dragon
this theory is based on the fact that
monkey d dragon doesn't exactly look
like his father garp but he does look
quite a bit like the few images that
we've seen of zebek according to this
theory zebic had his young 17 year old
son with him at god valley and after his
defeat zebek's son was taken in by garp
garp is actually luffy's maternal
grandfather and dragon became garp's
son-in-law after marrying his daughter
dragon began using the name a monkey
d-dragon instead of rocks the dragon
because he wanted to hide his connection
to zebic since that connection would
have made him a massive target in the
early stages of his life i mean as the
leader of the revolutionaries he is now
a massive target either way but that
would not have been the case back when
he was only 17 so the name change could
have made sense back then sadly this
theory doesn't really explain the
current whereabouts of luffy's mother or
why garp never talks about his own
daughter but it's an interesting idea
nonetheless then there's the crazy
theory that zebek may actually be
luffy's grandmother yes zebek was
actually a woman who adopted a masculine
persona in order to command more respect
in the traditionally male pirate world
there are actual historic examples of
this in our own world with female
pirates dressing up like men or even
posing as men during their pirating
careers and the idea here is that garp
and zebek were actually lovers but they
had a falling out when zebek decided to
declare war on the world government
dragon is actually the son of garp and
zebek and that is why he shares some of
zebec's physical features i'm not saying
that this is a likely theory but if
you've been holding out hope for an
intense romantic subplot featuring garp
then this is probably your best bet
another fun theory is that zebek may
actually be the father of shanks we've
always wondered why shanks and buggy
ended up on roger's ship at such a young
age and one possible explanation is that
shanks was zebek's son who was taken in
by roger after zebek's defeat at god
valley shanks would have only been like
one year old at the time so he wouldn't
even remember anything about zebek and
roger's crew would be the only family he
ever knew i personally really like this
theory if for no other reason than
because it would confirm shanks is a
member of the d-clan and seriously rox d
shanks sounds pretty badass shanks being
zebek's son who was rescued by roger as
a baby would also make for a great
addition to the god valley flashback and
since we know that shanks will come back
to the story sometime soon such a reveal
could be made when shanks and luffy
reunite finally there is the theory that
zebek is the father of blackbeard and
there are some direct connections
between these two infamous pirates for
one thing zebek and blackbeard are the
only two members of the d-clan who have
shown themselves to be ruthless and
machiavellian in the pursuit of their
ultimate goals
now all d-clan members seem destined to
change the world in some way but most of
them are fighting for freedom friendship
and other noble goals zebek and
blackbeard are clearly different and
they are willing to kill and destroy
everyone and everything that stands in
the way of their mission they believe in
freedom through power and they are
interested in absolute freedom for
themselves at the expense of others
luffy roger dragon and other d-clan
members seem more interested in freedom
for everyone and they are motivated by
things like friendship and loyalty not
greed and power on top of that
blackbeard even named his ship the sabre
of zebek which suggests that blackbeard
wants to embrace zebek's mission and
legacy some have suggested that the
yamami nomi blackbeard's first devil
fruit once belonged to zebik and that is
why blackbeard was so determined to find
this one specific fruit blackbeard would
have been about two years old when the
god valley incident occurred so
theoretically he could be zebek's son
who is determined to get revenge for his
father that said he could also just
admire zebek's ambition and thirst for
power as well as zebec's willingness to
boldly stand against the entire world
the big question is this
is zebek really dead like sengoku
suggests or is he still out there
somewhere if zebec is somehow still
alive then the theory that he had the
yami yami no me wouldn't make sense but
if he really is dead then this theory is
plausible blackbeard seems to be
consciously following in zebek's
footsteps he made hachinosu his base of
operations just like zebek he named his
ship the sabre of zebek and if the zebek
yamiyami nomi theory is correct then we
know that blackbeard did everything in
his power to consume zebek's former
devil fruit blackbeard also has the same
machiavellian ruthlessness as zebek did
and it's almost certain that blackbeard
shares the same ultimate goal as zebic
he wants to succeed where zebek failed
by overthrowing the world government and
becoming the king of the world and he
doesn't want to achieve this through
liberation but through domination i plan
to dive into blackbeard's secret master
plan in another video but in the
meantime let me know what you guys think
is zebek really dead or could he be
alive could zebec be luffy's other
grandpa or is he maybe shanks's father
or blackbeard's dad take a few seconds
and drop me a comment down below i'd
love to get a good conversation going if
you're looking for a video to watch next
check out my video on all the known
d-clan members and their powers link in
the description don't forget to like and
subscribe if you enjoyed the video it
really helps me out a lot and of course
it's completely free and you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys